today we're gonna be looking at SCP 55
object class Keter special containment
procedures object is kept within a five
by five by two point five meter square
room constructed of cement 50
centimeters thickness with a Faraday
cage surrounding the cement walls access
is via a heavy containment door
measuring 2 by 2.5 meters constructed on
bearings to ensure door closes and locks
automatically unless held open
deliberately security guards are not to
be posted outside SCP 55s room it is
further advised that all personnel
maintaining or studying other SCP
objects in the vicinity try to maintain
a distance of at least 50 meters from
the geometric center of the room as long
as this is reasonably practical
description SCP 55 is a self keeping
secret or anti meme information about
SCP 55 s physical appearance as well as
its nature behavior and origins is self
classifying to clarify how site 19
originally acquired SCP 55 is unknown
when SCP 55 was obtained and by whom is
unknown SCP 50 finds physical
appearances unknown it is not
indescribable or invisible individuals
are perfectly capable of entering a CP
55 s container and observing it taking
mental or written notes making sketches
taking photographs and even making audio
video recordings
an extensive log of such observations is
on file however information about SCP
55s physical appearance leaks out of a
human mind soon after such an
observation
individuals tasked with describing SCP
55 afterwards find their minds wandering
and lose interest in the tasks
individuals tasked with sketching a copy
of a photograph of SCP 55 are unable to
remember what the photograph looks like
as researchers are overseeing these
tests the security personnel who have
observed SCP 55 by closed-circuit
television cameras emerge after a full
shift exhausted and effectively amnesic
about the events of the previous hours
who authorized the construction of SCP
55 s containment room why it was
constructed in this way or what the
purpose of the describe containment
procedures may be are all unknown
despite NCP 55 s container being easily
accessible all personnel at site 19
claimed no knowledge of SCP 55 s
existence and challenged all of these
facts are periodically rediscovered
usually by chance of readers of this
file causing a great deal of alarm the
state of concern lasts minutes at most
before the matter is simply forgotten
about
a great deal of scientific data has been
recorded from SCP fifty-five but cannot
be studied at least one attempt has been
made to destroy a CB 55 or possibly move
it from containment site 19 to another
site meeting failure for reasons unknown
SCP 55 may present a major physical
threat and indeed may have killed many
hundreds of personnel and we would not
know it certainly it presents a gigantic
mimetic and mental threat hence its
Keter classification
document number 50 5-1 an analysis of
SCP 55 the author puts forward the
hypothesis that SCP 55 was never
formally acquired and is in fact an
autonomous remotely controlled agent
inserted at site 19 by an unidentified
party for one or all of the following
purposes to silently observe or
interfere with activities at site 19 to
silently observe or interfere with
activities at other SCP locations to
silently observe or interfere with
activities of humanity worldwide to
silently observe or interfere with other
SCP objects
and finally to silently observe or
interfere with God no action to counter
any of these potential threats is
suggested or indeed theoretically
possible
addendum a hey if this thing is really
an anti meme why doesn't the fact that
it's an anti meme get wiped we must be
wrong about that somehow wait a minute
what if we were able to keep notes about
what it isn't would we remember those
bartholomew hughes NSA document 55 - to
report of dr. john marachek survey team
number 19 - 55 - 1 - 7 b x e was
successfully able to enter SCP 55s
container and ascertained the appearance
and to some degree the nature of the
object notes were taken according to the
project methodology seed after which the
container was sealed again excerpt from
a transcript of personnel debriefing
follows dr. Hughes ok I'm going to need
to ask you some questions about number
55 now redacted number 1 dr. Hughes SCP
object 55 the object that you just
examined redacted um I don't know what
you're talking about I don't think we
have a 55 dr. Hughes ok then redact I'd
like you to tell me what you've been
doing for the past two hours redacted
what I
subject appears uncomfortable I don't
know dr. Hughes okay then do you
remember that we all agreed that it
wasn't spherical redacted that what
wasn't oh right it isn't round at all
object 55 isn't round dr. Hughes so you
remember it now redacted well no I mean
I don't know what it is but I know there
is one it's something you can't remember
and it's not a sphere dr. Hughes wait a
minute what's not a sphere redacted
object 55 dr. Hughes object what
redacted doc do you remember agreeing
that something wasn't shaped like a
sphere dr. Hughes oh right it appears to
be possible to remember what SCP 55 is
not negations of fact and to repeatedly
deduce its existence from these memories
personnel involved in survey number 1955
one to seven bxe reported moderate
levels of disorientation and
psychological trauma associated with the
cycles of repeated memory and
forgetfulness of SCP fifty-five however
no long-term behavioral or health
problems were observed and psych
assessments of survey personnel showed
consistent reports of this distress
fading over time recommendations it may
be worthwhile to post at least one staff
member capable of remembering the
existence of SCP 55 to each critical
site this has been SCP Winn
[Music]
you